I think we're now ready to tackle the
big picture and what has our government
officials so worried right now so what
I've done is I've just drawn the balance
sheets for a bunch of banks obviously
this is simplified and I made all of
their balance sheets look the same all
of these banks each of these kind of
represents the balance sheet of a bank
and just to explain it the left-hand
side of this balance sheet so this
column right here maybe I can for the at
least for this first bank I can mark a
little bit so what I'm squaring off in
magenta let me do a thicker what I'm
squaring off there that's the assets of
that Bank when I'm squaring off in la in
blue that's the liabilities of the bank
and what I wrote here has four billion
of liabilities its assets I divided it
between three billion of other assets
and two billion of CDOs because we want
to focus on the CDO because that's the
crux of everything that's going on and
we have five billion in assets four
billion of liabilities so you have 1
billion in equity so that's what's left
there so that just this is just another
visual representation that liabilities
plus equity is equal to assets or assets
minus liabilities is equal to equity and
I've just copied and pasted this one
balance sheet a bunch of times I've been
I don't know how much whether we're
going to use all of those but let's just
assume for simplicity that a ton of
banks in the system have this identical
balance sheet obviously they don't have
an identical balance sheet but they cut
all of their balance sheets might have
kind of the similar properties where
where the the part representing the CDO
and I'm doing this this isn't always the
case different banks have different
exposures to CDOs some of them have a
lot some of them a little bit some of
them are valuing them more
conservatively than others but just for
the sake of simplicity I've just made
all of the banks in a situation where
the what the book value of the CDOs that
they have on their balance sheet it's
larger than their equity value and I did
that for a reason
because it leads to the issue of are
these banks facing just a liquidity
issue are they facing just a solvency
issue if you believe that you know these
are worth 3 billion these assets these
liabilities worth 4
then the crux of whether it's a
liquidity or a solvency issue all falls
down as to whether these are worth two
billion or not for example even then you
have a billion dollars of equity right
if these are worth 1.5 billion well
maybe they're being a little optimistic
here but you'll still have point five
billion of equity so you're still
solvent right and in that situation in
theory one is just if they don't have
the cash when some of their debt comes
due they should just be able to borrow
some money and get past that hurdle and
then in the future maybe sell their
assets and still have positive equity
however if the true value of those CDOs
and this is kind of a philosophical
question what's the true value of
anything and the best thing that we as
humans have been able to come up with is
a market for you know the market value
tends to be the best representation of
the true value of something but if the
market value or that let's say the true
value of this is a billion dollars or
less then we have a situation for
example if these are worth nothing then
we only have three billion of assets
four billion of liabilities we have
negative equity the this company is
worth nothing and to lend this Bank or
this company any money would just be
throwing good money after bad because
you're not that money is just going to
go into a black hole because one of the
people who this company owes money to is
probably not going to see their money so
and if you are the most junior person
lending the money which means that when
all the money is distributed if they go
into bankruptcy you're the last person
to see the money then you're just
throwing good money after bad so that's
the issue but I want you to see the big
picture now because if it was just an
issue with one bank it wouldn't be a big
deal if it was just Bear Stearns or four
it was just Lehman Brothers not a big
deal let the greedy bankers go bankrupt
and you know they probably are doing
just fine with the bonuses they've
collected after sourcing these CDOs for
the past eight years or five years or
however long but what I want to show you
in this video is what people are talking
about when they say systemic risk so
these four billion in liabilities right
these are loans maybe from other banks
in fact probably from other banks and
those loans from other banks those are
assets of other banks for example maybe
a billion let's say the
is Bank a this is Bank B maybe a billion
of these are a loan from Bank B right so
this is a loan from Bank B and if this
is a loan from Bank B Bank B would have
an asset called a loan to bank a write
on banks B balance sheet we're calling
this a loan to bank a this isn't one of
its asset and then one of its
liabilities will be a loan from Bank B
right so how can I say it so let's say
they took this money and they gave it to
be sorry B had money gave it to a is
firm form of a loan right and so that
cash ended up here and that they got an
asset called loan to bank a and this is
a liability loan from Bank B and then
they might have taken that money and
they might have lent it to Bank
I don't know Bank C down here I think
you're you're starting to see how this
gets gets pretty hairy very fast right
so let's say that they Bank a one of its
three billion in assets let's say it is
a loan let me do that in a different
color it has a loan to bank C right so
this is it gave money to Bank C and so
on Banksy's balance sheet it'll say loan
from Bank A or so we owe a a billion
dollars right and a says OC owes me a
billion dollars and that's all fine and
then you see that oeob a billion dollars
and then we could you know we could keep
doing this or I could just even make
this into a circle already so maybe Bank
B has some money that it owes to someone
else and let's say that someone else
just for fun just to make this
interesting I think you can see you can
extrapolate and think about how this
gets complicated very fast Bank B has
borrowed money from Bank C so Bank C
will have an asset here that says no I
lent money to bank B so they lent money
to bank B fair enough okay so now we're
an interesting situation let's say this
loan loan from Bank B to loan a comes
due and we've studied this multiple
times let's say that this comes due
and let's say for whatever reason all of
these other loans they're there they're
not liquid you know they're not due yet
so Bank a can't get rid of these loans
so the situation here is that they would
either have to get some type of so let's
say say this comes due this is four
billion dollars they can't sell any of
this so they have to come up Bank a has
to come up with a billion dollar somehow
for Bank B right so that's the situation
we're dealing with I'm just going to say
that they can't sell any of these assets
so it all comes down to CDOs
so there's a couple of issues here if
you think it is just an issue of
illiquidity if these are two billion
dollars of assets they're really worth
two billion but bank aid just can't sell
them because either there's
quote/unquote no one willing to buy
although I would argue if no one is
willing to buy something then it's true
value is probably zero but let's just
say Bank a says oh no no one's willing
to buy we're just illiquid this is
really worth 2 billion so one situation
is they could get a loan from someone
maybe the Fed it would be willing to
take this as collateral so they would
give this as collateral to the Fed maybe
the Fed will give them a billion dollar
loan and then they can use that to pay
Bank B let's say that's off the table
because this is just toxins Meli enough
collateral than not even the Fed which
we now realize is willing to do anything
to support the markets then not even the
Fed is willing to give them a loan or
enough of a loan to pay off that loan
the other situation is maybe they can
get an equity infusion from a sovereign
wealth fund and we covered that a couple
of videos ago where the sovereign wealth
fund will essentially inject some cash
it'll dilute the shares and that you
know maybe we had 500 million shares
before now we'll have 2 billion shares
so the sovereign wealth fund will take
over roughly what's 2 billion over when
was that 80% of the company and in
exchange for 80% of the company would
give maybe 2 billion dollars and then
you could use that to pay off this loan
but let's say that that's not on the
table anymore either because the
sovereign wealth funds have gotten
burned so much right so what happens
well we learned what happens if you
can't get a loan a new loan to replace
this loan or if you can't get an equity
infusion from kind of a greater fool
what happens you go into bankruptcy and
this is what happened to leave in
brothers Lehman Brothers went into
bankruptcy no sovereign wealth fund no
one else bought the company and I should
probably do another video on that send
and they couldn't get alone so they went
bankrupt I should call this company l
actually but I'll call it company for
now because I don't want to I don't want
to impugn anyone actually don't think
Lehmann was any worse or better than any
of the other players here so when they
go into bankruptcy something very
interesting happens now bank B you know
they were already worried about these
CDOs right these CDOs were already an
issue and they were probably thinking
boy when when loan C comes due I'm going
to be in trouble or one loan D or F or
whatever it'll see I'm going to be in
trouble because I'm going to be in that
situation that Bank a is that I'm
essentially forcing Bank a into right
now but now I have a new problem this
loan to bank a isn't getting paid off
right this loan to bank a isn't getting
paid off and who knows Bank a is going
to go into bankruptcy Bank a is going to
bankruptcy maybe in bankruptcy we
realize that these are worth nothing and
if those are worth nothing then maybe
you know I'm very junior in seniority in
terms of where my loan is and maybe I
get nothing or get a few pennies on the
dollar here so maybe I thought this was
a billion dollars and I have to write
this down 2.5 billion dollars so now I
have two problems I have this and I have
this and once again this is a non liquid
loan right this isn't Bank A's and
bankruptcy and if I wanted to somehow
get the value of this I have to wait for
all of Bank A's assets to go into
liquidation and then I would have to
whatever assets I get I would have to
sell it so this is kind of a frozen
asset so once again I'm stuck holding
this non liquid asset so I have this
long liquid asset that's probably not
worth what I thought it was which was a
loan to a then I also have these CDOs
and now god forbid you know let's say
that I had another loan to bank D right
this is Bank D and now let's say Bank D
goes bankrupt and then I have another
loan that's bad on top of these CDOs but
as the CDOs were the crux of the issue
right that's what caused the situation
if bank a could have only sold this CDO
for two billion dollars it wouldn't have
caused this chain reaction right and
this you could Lehman Brothers really
was the thing
at that that catalyzed this whole this
whole chain of events right and then you
can imagine how Banksy is wired because
now Bank B has all of these illiquid
assets on top of the CDO so it starts to
look bad and you can imagine now it's
even less likely that when a bank let's
say that Bank D is the next one to go
into a dire situation it's even less
likely that Bank D can get a loan from a
third Bank because although all the
banks are getting scared now
all the mechs are i'm not going to loan
money to anyone if I can get any cash
from anybody I'm just going to keep it
so that when it's my turn when the
market starts looking at me I at least
have a little cash so everyone is frozen
everyone wants to collect their loans
from everyone else and no one wants to
give loans to anybody else so that's the
situation we're ending and that's the
the the difficulty that the Fed is
somehow trying to unwind and I realize
that a lot of time again I will I will
confront that issue in the next video